el barrio el fama es uno de los más
turísticos de la capital portuguesa
louis miembro de una asociación de
protección del vecindario lo recorre
desde hace más de 30 años
louis es un amante de este barrio desde
hace 30 años es miembro de una
asociación para su protección para el
este éxito perjudica a sus habitantes
en tres años los precios aumentaron un
64 en lisboa
más de la mitad de las casas de alfama
son air bien visto alrededor del 60 por
ciento depende así que con la pandemia y
el cese de los flujos de turistas el
vecindario está vacío es un vuelo
fantasma
now tesis en ti son secos chau
la alcaldía aparto un presupuesto de 15
millones de euros para poder alquilar
esas viviendas vacías a través de un
programa llamado renta segura arriendo
garantizado en español
hacemos contratos de cinco años a los
propietarios proponemos pagar tres años
de alquiler por adelantado y luego los
suv arrendamos a la generación más joven
ya la clase media él adquiere máximo que
tienen que pagar por este apartamento es
un tercio de sus ingresos netos
el objetivo es recuperar mil
apartamentos para que la gente de lisboa
pueda reapropiarse del centro de la
ciudad
sientes tenemos que ofrecer a sus
clientes la ayuda de arriendo garantizar
dentro de las agencias inmobiliarias ya
ayudaron a incluir unos 200 apartamentos
en el programa
con crear así que muy concretamente para
este apartamento originalmente el
alquiler era de 1.400 euros pero el
propietario después de impuestos recibió
900 euros
entonces para este cliente la exención
de impuestos hace que sea muy
interesante ser parte del programa
diana fue una de las primeras
propietarias en firmar este verano
[Música]
a
esa es la sala de estar en el salón este
es uno de los primeros dormitorios
para esta franco-portuguesa es una
oferta en la que todos ganan tanto los
propietarios como los inquilinos
pierde 400 al mes pero con más seguridad
y al mismo tiempo la gente puede tener
una vivienda de la que de otra manera no
tendría acceso
si no estás tan no para entonces todos
contentos no del todo según
organizaciones como la de louis que
denuncia a una ayuda costosa que no
resuelve la crisis de la vivienda
sólo hay 200 apartamentos para viajar
solicitantes así que hay una gran
demanda pero poco fértil y otra crítica
es que este programa subvención en el
sector privado de los que deberían big
program es bing a sus edades inter
private sector
ambiente
entre los que se han quedado atrás está
maría neves una pintora está en la
incapacidad de pagar su alquiler y corre
el riesgo de que la expulsen
cuando llueve afuera también llueve
adentro se filtra mucha agua
como muchos lisboetas en esta situación
precaria no puede beneficiarse de
ninguno de los programas de la alcaldía
me siento abandonada como mucha gente
para mí este programa no es bueno porque
cinco años después el problema seguiría
siendo el mismo así que me siento en
riesgo todo el día
[Música]
según la asociación de derecho a una
vivienda más de 50 mil familias de la
capital viven en condiciones precarias